you're right I shouldn't have stolen  from a two-dimensional creature I'm  gonna put these gems back in the safe  but I would like to leave some evidence  of my presence the 2D creature is  outside at the moment and is wearing a  cap  if I were to pick it up  and rotate it in the third dimension  and then place it back  that might be enough of a clue that I  visited no one in the second dimension  could have done this because it required  a movement in the third dimension and no  one in 2D will ever be able to rotate it  back to normal so the backwards cap  might just be more valuable than any of  the gems because it is evidence of a  higher dimension